This shot is a rough version
of the final battle in
"Avengers: Endgame."
And it looks pretty similar
to what you saw in theaters.
But the process of putting
this rough shot together
began three years before
the movie came out --
well before the actors went on set
and before a single frame
was captured on camera.
These rough shots are called previs,
short for previsualization.
Essentially, this tool allows filmmakers
to digitally map out how they
want any given scene to look.
Directors can then use the previs
as a guide for how to film scenes,
sometimes frame for frame,
once everyone's on set.
Previs has been around for a long time.
But in earlier movies,
it was used in a much more limited way.
Chris Edwards: They were used for just
small pockets of that movie.
For the one big visual effect shot,
for the big finale sequence.
Narrator: But now, instead
of just using previs
in small doses, companies
like The Third Floor
have developed it into a tool
for designing entire movies.
And no studio's embraced that
approach more than Marvel,
which has enlisted the
help of The Third Floor
for 19 of the 23 films
in its Infinity Saga.
For 2014's "Captain America:
The Winter Soldier,"
Marvel had gotten to the point
of previsualizing two-thirds of a movie.
Today, the studio is
known to use visualization
to map out every single scene.
Not just action scenes, either;
for "Endgame," The Third
Floor's work touched everything
from the comedic scene
with Hulk in the diner
to emotional moments like
the one between Hawkeye
and Black Widow on Vormir,
leaving nothing up to chance
in one of the most
expensive movies ever made.
The first visualizations of a Marvel film
will often begin before the
script's fully finished.
Chris: And that actually is the best place
for a professional visualization team,
is to be able to make bridges
and try out some experiments
between departments that have a crazy idea
that may or may not work.
You want to be able to
throw things at walls
and see if they stick.
Narrator: Occasionally, rough
previs might be underway
even before the cinematographer
or director has signed on to the project,
a practice that can be
controversial in Hollywood.
Director Lucrecia Martel said
she turned down the offer
to direct the upcoming "Black Widow" movie
after Marvel told her not to worry
about the action sequences.
It is true that Marvel
encourages their team
of previs artists to play an active role
in story development.
Jeff Ford, the editor for "Endgame,"
said that The Third Floor's
visualization supervisor
Gerardo Ramirez, who'd worked
on nine prior Marvel films,
was like an additional director, writer,
and editor on the project.
That's because previs artists are involved
in just about everything from the start,
helping to map out story beats and shots
and consulting on everything
from blocking, staging,
lighting, how heroes will use
their power in big fights,
and even the timing and
tone of any given scene.
To understand just how crucial previs is
to Marvel's process,
let's go back to that final
battle from "Endgame,"
specifically the "Avengers
assemble" moment,
when all the heroes return
one by one through portals.
The Third Floor presented Marvel
with two previs'd takes
on that arrival moment.
One was slower and more emotional,
while the other was higher energy
and had the heroes arriving mid-charge.
Ultimately, Marvel went with
a blend of the two versions.
A lot of this is done to save money.
Today's previs tools allow filmmakers
to do virtual location scouting
and test out advanced camera work.
Take, for example, the Sony/Marvel movie
"The Amazing Spider-Man,"
which was shot in 3D.
The filmmakers wanted to have
some cool first-person shots
of Spider-Man swinging through New York,
but they didn't want to
make audiences nauseous.
So they used previs from the
visualization studio Proof
to determine how much
and what type of movement
people would be able to handle.
All of this is then
extracted into a blueprint
for production called techvis,
which provides filmmakers
with all the data and diagrams
they'll need to actually
recreate each shot in real life.
Essentially, this is where
all the detailed math happens.
Remember this scene from "Thor: Ragnarok,"
where Heimdall leads the
Asgardians across the bridge?
The Third Floor did the
techvis for that crane shot
to work out the camera
height and lenses they'd need
along with the distance from which
they'd film the characters.
For "Endgame," they
produced over 100 different
technical mock-ups containing
information like this,
all of it accurate to the real locations
and equipment they'd be using.
Getting all the numbers down pat
is especially important
for a movie like "Ant-Man,"
where characters dramatically
fluctuate in size
from one moment to the next,
or "Doctor Strange," where
the folding-city imagery
required a lot of dimensional mathematics.
And techvis is useful
for quieter beats, too.
Marvel used it to define
the camera parameters
for this weighty scene between Hawkeye
and Black Widow in "Endgame"
to make sure they'd hit the
right tone and visual impact.
Filmmakers can even plug
the data from techvis
into a motion-control-camera system,
which lets you program precise,
repeatable camera movements.
Chris: They're also well
versed in programming
robotic dollies, robotic cranes
that move the camera around.
Narrator: Setting up
such a tightly controlled
shooting environment can
speed up production a lot.
And when you're on location
for a Marvel movie,
every minute counts.
The visualization process
doesn't end with shooting, though.
The Third Floor's work on a Marvel film
can run all the way up to
the end of postproduction
because of the process called postvis.
This involves taking a
live-action photography
they've shot and combining
it with the previs elements.
Take this moment in "Endgame,"
where Strange, Spider-Man,
and Star-Lord join the final battle.
The Third Floor started
with completely digital
previs and techvis for the shot,
which Marvel then used to film
the actors on a green screen.
Next, The Third Floor reintroduced
some key previs elements,
like the background and
the outline of the portal.
For "Endgame," The Third
Floor's artists made
7,300 previs shots.
Over 7,000 of those ultimately
became postvis shots.
The postvis shots serve as placeholders
in early cuts of the film,
allowing Marvel to quickly preview it
before commissioning
the finishing effects.
Marvel will often screen
these versions of the film,
filled with postvis, in
front of test audiences
to get an idea of how the
film might be received.
Plus, the postvis shots provide a template
to the VFX artists who take on the movie's
final effects work.
Using visualization from beginning to end
can save Marvel millions on
expensive effects and shoots.
And, ultimately, having all the
technical stuff squared away
will ideally free up
the director to focus on
getting the best performances
from their actors on set.
Chris: They can be warned
about things that are
up and coming that might
impact their craft,
so that they're not surprised about it
when they walk onto the set.
Narrator: But doesn't
having all of these shots
pre-rendered diminish
the role of directors
on Marvel movies?
Not necessarily.
Another advantage of
in-depth visualization
is that Marvel isn't limited
to hiring big action directors.
The studio's become known
for their unconventional director choices,
often pulling talent from
the indie or TV circuit.
Chris: And that's where
they can really benefit
also from the previs process,
as they can trust a team like ours
to work with the stunt coordinator,
so that all they have to do is
be like an avid viewer of their own film
as it's coming together
and to be making comments,
like they do with everything else.
Narrator: Some directors might chafe
at Marvel's wide-ranging use of previs.
Others may welcome the
fact that Marvel has
a dedicated team of previs
artists and VFX specialists
who know how to plan out action sequences.
Marvel's extensive use of visualization
has helped the franchise
maintain a coherent vision
all the way through "Endgame."
Given Marvel's box-office dominance,
other studios may follow their model
of embracing visualization,
even for smaller productions.
The Third Floor has worked on a number
of nonaction films in recent years,
from art flicks like
2016's "Nocturnal Animals"
to political biopics like 2018's "Vice."
Chris: Now that the
digital world is merging in
with the physical world, that
is going to be the future
of a lot larger swaths of content creation
than just these very
ambitious productions.